une fois de plus.
Notre envoyée spéciale
Marie-Eve Béda
- Les ruines fumaient
encore au lever évévévévévévévée
que le cratère creusé au sol par
l'explosion de la nuit dernière.
Sous les décombres, les morts.
Ils sontun bilan encore proviso.
Les services de secours
y ont passé la nuit et
à la recherche de survivants.
Ce sont surtout les morts
qu'ils ont extirpés des cendres
la guerre s'est rapprochée
du centre de Kiev. Pour les
habitants du quartier de Podil,
"D'abord, j'ai vu une énorme
exioioion, raconte Dima.
Puis le flash a illuminé ma
devant. Une puissante explosion
m'm'm'a jeté hors de mon lit."
Cette explosion, la voici,
sécurité près du centre
commercial Retroville,
qui a été en partie soufflé
par la p
"C'est difficile pour moi de
travaillait ici", dit Valentina.
é é é était au travail hier
et cette chose s'est produite
hier soir. L L L L L L L L L L s
autour de la capitale semble
figée depuis près d'une semaine.
Mais en revanche, les tirs et
s'intensifient depuis 24 heures.
Encore visiblement trop loin
pour des tirs d'artillerie,
essentiellement aux frappes de
missiles et tirorororoquettes.
Une tactique qui sèmeu u u u ua
population, accuse Ulana Supun.
Elle et son mari avaient
brièvement succombé à llslslslst
revenus.
Le couple a choisi de défier
l'attaque russe en relançant
depuis la capitale.
Ulana, qui est aussi
américaine, a été ministre
un canado-ukrainien, est
journaliste et activiste.
(mus
Une autre mélodie quis
familière vient interrompre
notre entretien. Soudainement,
le temps s'arrête sur la placepi
accompagne beaucoup de jeunes
mariés pour leur première danse.
(musique)
résonnent comme le serment
de foi de tous les Ukrainiens.
"Je vais rêver et vivre
de l'espoir. Comment ne pas
t'aimer, Kiev ma chérie?"
Ici Marie-Eve Bédard,